yeah yeah man gang [ __ ] is G herbo
survivors of Morris check me out on the
bootleg Kev podcast game
bootleg cab show we got a special guest
in the building survivor's remorse comes
out Friday yes sir G herbo my guy my
brother my brother good to see you man
always likewise uh survivor's remorse is
a uh
that's a deep title man and it's
something that a lot of people go
through you know when you come from
certain backgrounds and you know you
learn you learn or you lose people in
your life to the streets to other things
like kind of dive into let's just kick
it off Man dive into survivor's remorse
bro
survivor's remorse man for me is
you know it's it's deeper than just the
album title is
where I am mentally in my life you know
what I'm saying as a man
um having overcame so much adversity and
like
bro it's it's crazy because my
circumstance when I first started
rapping let me just go back to in
general when I first started rapping
when I first made my first ever rap
Howard I wasn't trying to I was
the first time I made a rap like on some
like murder of [ __ ] yeah yeah little
herb [ __ ]
15 15 years old okay
um probably 14 14 going on 15 or
something like that I was 14 a freshman
in high school so like 14 or 15.
um
and when I did that I wasn't trying to
like
become a rapper like my dreams and
aspirations was never to become a rapper
like I want to become this big Superstar
nothing like that I was rapping trying
to like put on for my hood be the voice
for my neighborhood you know what I'm
saying and talk about what I was feeling
what I was going through like I wasn't I
didn't know what a manager was an A and
R uh record label I didn't know what
none of that was bro I didn't know
anything about that
I just was recording a song on my app on
my flip phone over a YouTube beat and I
send it to my homies for them to hear
you know what I'm saying it just picked
up naturally you know and I still wasn't
it didn't grasp me you know what I'm
saying I'm saying that to say like I
mean you're a kid I was a kid you feel
me and when I started to
become a rapper I was still a kid you
know so survivors remorse for me is
coming from that being in the most
dangerous neighborhood you know I'm
saying one of the most dangerous
neighborhoods in Chicago and just trying
to find a way to get my thoughts out you
know I'm saying I always knew how to rap
it was just a way for me to like Express
what I'm going through in the hood and
for my homies to hear it to relate to it
you know what I'm saying and to have
that and turn it into this and to be
able to overcome
deaf prison
uh drug addiction like all of that all
of these things and BG herbo today be
who I am today you know what I'm saying
and that's what being a Survivor is for
me you know I'm saying I survived my
circumstance I don't never have to go
back to living that way you know what
I'm saying and the remorse side of it is
everything I lost along the way you know
a lot of my best friends my brother
um
just so much you know just in the
thought of so many people that I love
that I actually care about still being
in poverty still being under these
circumstances you know I'm saying that
me wanting to help them me wanting to
show them this other side of life
because I've experienced it and
understanding that you can't do that for
everybody understanding that everybody
not gonna want that for themselves you
know and
it's a constant battle you feel I'm
saying like
I have to to smile and be charismatic
and do interviews be a leader press be a
leader you know what I'm saying be a
role model for so many people that look
up to me and I don't get a chance to
really just sit back and
reflect on life or sit back and just you
know feed my my mental stability you
know what I'm saying like yeah and
grieve or whatever the case may be you
know what I'm saying I can't really have
a bad day all day there's no such thing
as me really being mad all day I've
never experienced it for real you don't
have the luxury of it I don't have the
luxury to just be pissed off all day or
be sad all day I don't have it right so
that's the remorse side of it you know
what I'm saying like and that's crazy
and I'm blessed to just be the type of
person where I'm not even that kind of
guy like no matter what I'm going
through or how I'm feeling I'm not gonna
never be mad upset all day angry all day
I don't even understand how that's
possible Right but people really like
that people really walk around mad sad
angry all day because of what they going
through and I just know I'm blessed no
matter what it is I don't give a [ __ ] if
I was dead broke I've experienced enough
life to know that I'm blessed no matter
what I'm alive my kids good whatever the
[ __ ] the case may be you know what I'm
saying so that's survivor's remorse to
me you know just where I am mentally
like you know what I'm saying just
trying to
create balance for myself you feel me
because
at the end of the day you don't really
change I'm still that same person and
that's probably the deepest explanation
that I've given about the title you know
what I'm saying because I'm still that
same person I'm still that same kid from
same life as you feel me but I'm G herbo
I'm a father I'm a leader I'm a a
philanthropist I'm so many things where
I can't really dwell on one moment I
just gotta keep on trying to get better
and better and that's if I was immersed
you know I'm saying I just gotta you
know keep a Level Playing Field would
you say that when you get into those uh
mind states where you're very like you
start thinking about [ __ ] like that do
you look to your kids as like an as the
number one way to push through a small
that's my number one Outlet yeah other
than like the studio and you know what
I'm saying just having fun with the
people I love my family you know what
I'm saying
um my girl and [ __ ] like that like
that's the only piece that I really have
you feel when this
Smiles happiness I don't like arguing I
don't like confrontation because
I can't you know balance my emotions I
have to keep my emotions bottled in one
place so I don't like confrontation I
don't like to
especially with people that I care about
because I don't want to of course
release that angle yeah I'm saying so my
only like pure form or like pieces being
with my kids at all bro like period
that's the only time I could think about
nothing in the world or Nothing Else
Matters I can't be angry around my kids
all they want to do is play and smash
right right right right right right yeah
and you have you have a lot like you're
living for them now you know what I'm
saying not just yourself
do you uh you know I I I think that
there's something to be said like
anybody who's in a leadership
uh role I feel like a lot of people
depend on you
um you're a young leader in hip-hop but
it just in terms of just your life your
life your personal spiritual life
everybody 100 everyone's looking at you
every single person in my life depends
on me whether it's financially whether
it's leadership emotional whatever it is
opportunity emotional everybody in my
life depends on me for something you
know I'm saying I depend on them for
things too of course but it's a
double-sided relationship you know what
I'm saying but I have the most
responsibility so I gotta carry myself
that way you know I'm saying I can't
take nothing personal I gotta go and get
this [ __ ] because life is not a promise
so I'm here I'm Gonna Get Where I Wanna
Be and I'm going to put the people who I
want to put in position in position I'm
not going to take it personal I'm not
going to take a day off I'm not going to
waste a day right this [ __ ] could be
taken from me tomorrow 100 I can't wait
more than one way it could be taken from
me bro do you like my thing is though is
when you're in that position because I
find myself in a similar position
um like would you because because
like who do you go to because everyone's
gonna come to you with their [ __ ]
everyone will come to you with their
problems it depends I only have a
certain a few people that I could really
go to like if you're having a bad day
who do you go to like who do you depends
on what kind of bad day I'm having right
sometimes I go to nobody sometimes I'm
just I deal myself you know so off the
top of my head
um I know I could trust my therapist I
could go to her I could go to
JB for things I could go to make for
things I could go to jail for things you
know so I go to my big brother for
things
um I go to my mother for things you know
what I'm saying but overall it's like
I I feel like nobody really really
understand what I'm going through you
know what I'm saying so it's like a lot
of times I just keep it pushing you know
I mean to have a therapist that's nice
though and also to be great I mean
that's wonderful like I could tell her
anything you know what I'm saying like
just chill or whatever you know what I'm
saying but I feel like
and it's crazy the more my life is like
picked up and expanded I don't it's
therapy is not the same if I'm not in
front of her like I can't do zooms and
yeah that [ __ ] don't work for me because
that's something that's like
since the pandemic people are doing this
yeah it's not the same it don't work I
gotta get in front of her you know what
I'm saying so it's like once the
pandemic hit I kind of feel back off
therapy a little bit right it's not the
same Zoom [ __ ] it's the same thing with
interviews I tell people I'll pass on
the zoom yeah yeah the zoom interviews
or whatever unless it's like you know
necessary yeah the necessity of it got
to be you know but I'm like look I'd
rather wait till they're in LA and we
have to sit across from each other
absolutely because it's some more yeah
at what point in time because I do feel
like
everybody should go to therapy everybody
I don't care who you are I don't care if
you guys should definitely I recommend
everybody try it at least everyone
should try to have that outlet where you
could unapologetically just Express
Yourself
how long have you been uh going to
therapy I've been going to therapy since
2018. and that was by choice
Canada yeah it was by choice my lawyer
actually recommended it from me you know
what I'm saying I really I told my
lawyer you know I believe in honesty and
transparency you know so I was fighting
a gun case in Chicago that's it's behind
me now I remember yeah and I told my my
lawyer like I've never really not been a
fear of my life since I was 14 years old
crazy way to live 15 years old that's a
crazy way to wake up and live a lawyer
is a
uh he's uh over at he's 60 years old a
black man you know what I'm saying that
he I had two lawyers and I had a another
lawyer black woman she was in her 30s
you know 40s maybe and when I expressed
it to him they just refer like you need
to go to therapy and talk to somebody
you know what I'm saying and I did that
and within like my second third session
she literally went to court testified
for me well you know what I'm saying
wrote down and sent it to my my judge
and I was literally diagnosed with
post-traumatic stress disorder I've
never like still to this day and that's
why I believe the importance of like
security and all that [ __ ] because I'm
paranoid bro everywhere I go I've always
been paranoid and I'm kind of like
easing out of it now you know yeah but
you ease out of it and then you see you
ease out of it you see uh when your
comrades lose their life and when they
left that when they let their guard down
they snap you right back into it that's
what I'm saying I'm glad you made that
point because you ease out of it the
more you experience life the more you
see stuff the more you're able to travel
the more you're able to make money like
I was afraid for my life in Chicago I
moved to LA to get away from that [ __ ]
right and then you see somebody that you
love pnb Long Live my brother that's
what I'm talking about I love I love PMB
you see these things nip all these
people you know what I'm saying I came
here to get away from that [ __ ] and then
you like oh [ __ ] it's still like that
out here but at the end of the day it's
like that everywhere this is everywhere
no matter where you are anywhere in
another country it's like that
everywhere you know what I'm saying so
the realization of it is you can't put
your guard down so how do you deal with
it you know you also like I I also think
that like you just have to kind of
understand who you are exactly you're G
herbo so you're not gonna like you're
gonna take notes if you're if you're
self-aware and you're sure of yourself I
think there's certain ways you can move
around or if like absolutely if you get
caught slipping like you want my like
you want my iPhone I'll delete it go
ahead take it I'll believe it I'm that
type of guy I say that all the time I'll
look at the camera and say that I don't
have no ego it's not no
Gangsta bone in my body that's gonna
feel funny about like I I understand
that you know I'm saying God forbid if
I'm ever in that situation my pride will
never get in the way of me getting back
home to your kids family period ever
ever ever you could have that [ __ ] you
want the car I'll give you my car go
ahead take it I gotta Insurance
get away from me it's gonna be the most
cam robbery and it's not gonna be it's
gonna be don't touch me don't touch me
don't put your hands on me don't harm my
fat don't do nothing you can have this
[ __ ] man this [ __ ] ain't nothing it
ain't worth it it ain't never worth it I
could get it again you need it more than
a million more times you could have this
[ __ ] bro you could have my car you have
everything huh you need to get away car
take this [ __ ] yeah there's something
about PTSD that obviously uh an amazing
record of yours that was on your last
album yeah
um but it's something about PTSD that
you know we always think of soldiers
having it people who go to war but I
think that you know people who have been
through certain situations or grew up in
certain places is very real man and it's
like
have you tried to uh
have you ever tried to [ __ ] with
mushrooms at all no I ain't gonna lie
you know what's so crazy bro like long
ago I always wanted to try like like
years ago I always wanted to travel and
I used to be around juice all the time
I'm saying like I always wanted to try
that [ __ ] I ain't gonna lie but I never
tried it because I just feel like I need
to be in a set space you know what I'm
saying that's fair be in a set space
Maybe out the country with my family
having fun and I'll maybe try that [ __ ]
you feel I'm saying but I always wanted
to try though when you do it you
definitely have to have your guard fully
let down yeah
my brother I swear my brother told me
the story look this is my brother's name
G2 he an artist he signed the South Side
that's my brother hello he told me one
of his experiences on shrooms and this
is what made me want to try it yeah he
came in the studio I wasn't there he
came in the studio crying like crying
everybody like what's wrong what the
[ __ ] you crying for and [ __ ] said I'm
happy he said I'm crying because I'm so
[ __ ] happy and that [ __ ] threw me out
I started laughing so [ __ ] hard when
they told me that story and that's what
made me want the trash roll well like uh
there's
um
PTSD ins like specifically yeah
psilocybin which is the psychoactive
ingredient that are in magic mushrooms
you know whatever
um it cures it for soldiers right so
mushrooms though yes so in Portland you
heard it so in Portland but I'm saying
like and that's crazy you said that
because G2 is Street [ __ ] yeah that's
what I'm saying like it was a different
feeling for him like whatever the
psychedelics so like it's also I mean
obviously it depends on how much you eat
depends on what you know what I mean but
in uh so they just legalized uh
psilocybin therapy in Portland so like
now like there's like soldiers who will
just go to Portland for like two weeks
and they'll go see a therapist and they
do like some psilocybin therapy and man
it really helps the therapist get them
shrooms there yes but they give it yeah
and it helps with it really helps with
PTSD well just like a form of the trolls
basically yeah like Joe Biden just
talked about legalizing it for
therapeutic purposes because it helps
PTSD that's crazy
MDMA therapy which you said that I'll
probably have to try it you have to man
and you have to do it you have to do it
like make sure the kids ain't around
yeah for sure you can do it
recreationally and like be in the studio
and still kill it you know like I
[ __ ] was fried onions the other night
I never tried it but I want to try it
though I'm like but you gotta do it if
you really want to do it because I think
if you really like PT first person to
ever really introduced me to shrooms
with Southside Southside I already was
[ __ ] with the trolls he's [ __ ]
with everything yeah
yeah this is a party pack Sizzle is that
guy when it comes to just me my brother
no he's a great great guy me and him had
one of the funnest interviews I've ever
done and I appreciated this transparent
that's really like my twin brother he's
a great guy I wanna you know the one
thing I haven't done is party with them
and I'm not sure I want to but uh yeah
you you you not don't want to but you
guys don't know if I'm ready I don't
know if I'm ready that [ __ ] literally
me and him uh like
he's hilarious man yeah I didn't know
what to think yeah I'd met him before
back in the day and he came in for the
interview and he was just like an open
book and he's hilarious yeah super solid
exactly it's like he's solid but it's
like it's a whole other like
sad tool yeah they don't make it like
they don't make him like him he'll make
them like well I'm telling you like
that's my that's my best friend bro like
my mother loved him his mother loved me
like I know his whole family he know my
entire is amazing you know my whole
family definitely do the mushrooms man
yeah I think mentally it'll help you man
but you should do it one time but like
listen look they're on the back like hey
man I don't know why you want to
introduce this y'all
first of all it's not a drug it's not a
drug you could do your research on it
but get an Airbnb somewhere
in the [ __ ] Woods away from
everything exactly and try it eat a ton
and then just sit back and let it let
the medicine do its work but you know
this is so crazy because my mind
automatically like I I'm a thinker bro
my mind is like all over the place like
literally I think about sober I think
about every single obstacle in my life I
think about okay I make this decision
it's gonna affect this person this
person is always then you're am I cool
with that all right I'm cool with that
I'm gonna do it you feel that's how I
think automatically so on those shrooms
gonna open my [ __ ] up a different way
like even more even the smallest thing
like weed when I used to smoke weed bro
yeah I used to think differently you
know what I'm saying like when I drink
liquor I think differently but I'm a
thinker you know I never act off
emotions mushrooms will just sings a
certain way increase the thinking
exactly and I've heard it that's what
I'm saying yeah
I'm a natural thinker so I can only
imagine what my mind is going to do if I
take a shroom I got you man I own a
gummy company so yeah I'm gonna hook you
up we're gonna [ __ ] around I'm gonna hit
you I'm gonna hit you about it after I
tried I'ma call you you're gonna be the
first person I call like hey bro I'll
[ __ ] with you for that yeah you're gonna
like you're gonna close your eyes to go
to bed the night you try them and your
brain and then y'all see it President
Joe Biden already then God damn it the
goal is to leave
legalize uh psychedelic therapy and then
before if you want to say to Joe Biden
right now
I don't know you old as [ __ ]
I missed you know what I ain't gonna say
that I just missed prior to bite it I
miss my tax bills under Trump exactly
because God absolutely that's what I'm
telling you yo my team's gonna say what
details the taxes the IRS check I wrote
last year hurt my soul and I you make
way more money than me you know you know
I don't even want to talk about taxes
please don't you know what you got to do
is I have a few rapper friends that I
won't say because I'm not blowing up
their spot but what you do is you get
your primary residence
in either Nevada or Florida absolutely
that's where you live absolutely that's
where you live and then you don't got to
worry about state taxes
because California is [ __ ] you in
that [ __ ] you around oh my God it's
terrible it's bad I don't even know like
why I mean why does anybody live here I
know why I live here
but if I was doing literally anything
else with my life
I'm not this [ __ ] and I love I love
Cali I love the culture here I love the
people here I love it I just love it I
never thought that I would ever like
even want to move anywhere else you know
what I'm saying but tax purposes to make
you want to get the [ __ ] out of here I
mean yeah Elon Musk left Elon Musk is
like I'm going to Texas [ __ ] y'all no
[ __ ] yeah shout out to uh yeah but
we gotta get you some mushrooms man we
you said you would overcome uh drug
addiction what was what was the uh your
your poison uh Zan's Percocet and Lane
that's hard those are all the hard ones
all the hard was all the worst ones man
um those are the kind of ones yeah I got
addicted to zans and lean when I was
probably about 17 years old I was taking
his hands drinking lean smoking weed
like every day I ain't gonna like look I
used to I got to a point where my
brother he had to tell you the story I
wish he was here we was in New York one
time you know like 17 18. I'm already G
herbo I'm already well little herb or
whatever the [ __ ] I'm already traveling
I'm doing shows I'm in other states and
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying so I'm on
the road battling you know the trauma
that I'm TR that I've been dealing with
for so long you know what I'm saying but
um
I'm like one day we was in a hotel and
I'm seeing my brother right there I'm
just like taking zans take one I was
already off and I ain't feeling we just
in the room chilling like 30 40 minutes
go by I'll take another one
like I'll go by I'll take another look
at me like hey bro what the [ __ ] you
doing you feeding my brother like hey
[ __ ] I just watched you literally take
three take three of them yeah hose ends
back to back you drinking what the [ __ ]
is you doing right I'm like 17 18 years
old and my brother five years older than
me yeah he's like hey man what the [ __ ]
you on yeah and I ain't even realizing
you feel me like I ain't even feel like
I'm feeling I'm like I ain't high he
like [ __ ] I'm looking at you [ __ ] you
is high yeah you feel me like I was
battling with that [ __ ] crazy bro
because I couldn't sleep like trauma
things I'm seeing bro like I mean and
numbs you dealing with I've been saying
some Wicked [ __ ] bro I didn't see my
best friends brains blew out in front of
me I've been seeing a lot of [ __ ] bro
for real like it just got to a point
where I couldn't live with my
grandmother my grandmother died in 2016
bro I missed the last probably year and
a half of my grandmother life because I
couldn't live up I couldn't live there
bro I couldn't live that [ __ ] was
trying to kill me I couldn't you
couldn't be around here because you
couldn't be around the person who I love
the most because life because of where
she lived right and she ain't had no
choice she on [ __ ] section eight
right she can't move you feel I'm saying
like that [ __ ] bothered me still to this
day bro and I don't want to get
emotional about it but you can only
imagine like that's just one thing so
how about this so my grandma died of
covet early cover yeah so but this is
what was [ __ ] up if she was like
teetering on dementia so we'd have to go
and see her
like three or four times a week just to
remind her right so she would always if
my grandmother was like that she had a
stroke if I'm saying she had a stroke
and she was like you know trying to gain
her memory back you know what I'm saying
yeah but what was crazy was you remember
during covert they shut down all the um
the nursing homes so like the last two
months of my grandma's life we literally
were not allowed to visit her that's
crazy and they wouldn't they wouldn't
even like they would try to put us on
the phone with her you know what I'm
saying but like so she died Alone with
nobody around her without seeing anybody
for two months crazy bro I ain't gonna
lie and like I relate to that because
and I only want to get deep into it you
know what I'm saying but
I'ma just go into it [ __ ] it
my mother's mom she died from a stroke
her second stroke I caused her first
stroke I got into a fight at school when
I was in eighth grade [ __ ] and I told my
sister like run down the block and my
sister had a cell phone right we getting
into it with some [ __ ] after school
blase blah I tell my sister like run
down the street you know what I'm saying
and
my sister called like oh her being
fighting and scared my grandmother like
you know made her get scared and as soon
as I walked in the house after the [ __ ]
I walk home I'm in eighth grade as soon
as I walk in the house my grandma see me
she already like ecstatic like she's
already [ __ ] yeah it's older [ __ ]
though it's older than we got into some
[ __ ] that was like Junior seniors ice
cream we in eighth grade you feel I'm
saying so my my sister crying on the
phone she is static my grandma don't
know what the [ __ ] going on right so
when I get home and she see me walk in
she like already paranoid I promise I
went in the house for two minutes okay I
fell on the floor hit a stroke in front
of everybody you feel me and she
recovered from it she had surgery she
lost her memory all that you know what
I'm saying and then she had another
another
um another stroke maybe like
10 years later something like that you
know what I'm saying but like as I'm in
the streets and all this and I had to
move out of my grandmother's house and I
was still trying to like go see her you
know I remember my last time stepping
foot in my grandmother house I was
probably 18 19 years old my last time
stepping foot in her house
um
and I had a girl like drop me off like
I'm gonna go see my grandma real quick
right pulling me right there and my Ops
neighborhood it's just me and the girl
you feel me wow I go inside the crib I
got a big ass gun on me
big ass girl I don't know me my grandma
see it you feel me like
she like don't come back here no more
you know she's like oh he wants you to
come back here no more yeah it's cool
I'll call you I'll come see you if I'm
saying and that was the last time I went
to my grandma's house and then I moved
my mother when I started making money
the first thing I did the first big
check I really got for real I moved my
mama out the hood right I knew my
grandma wasn't moving she ain't going
nowhere I'm on my grandma an hour away
from Chicago my grandma already sick she
old she not driving an hour away to go
see nobody you feel me like my grandma
only been in my the mansion and I bought
my mama my grandma probably been there I
could count on one hand how many times
she's been there you feel me and
it was like I lost their memories with
my grandmother and that's who raised me
that's the woman I love the most you
feel me I lost those memories and what
I'm saying is I relate to what you're
saying because this is my mother's Mom
after covet my father's mom still I
haven't seen my father's mom in probably
two years right she's in a hospital
still to this day right now right now
you don't know what I'm doing hey she's
in the hospital to this day she called
covet and she was in like one of them
spots where covet was so crazy she
couldn't get no visitors yeah that's
limited visitors can't nobody even see
her but my mom my mom only see her maybe
once or twice right my dad could only go
see her they won't even let me see her
I'm G herbo I can't even go see my
grandmother for real that's what I'm
saying like and I think now I probably
can now but it's like it's two years ago
but my grandma
close to 80 years old right you feel I'm
saying she like 77 78.
close to 80 years old I can't even see
it you know what I'm saying this from
that [ __ ] with me all the time they [ __ ]
with me go see her man if you can only
Grandma yeah I don't even know if I can
I've been trying to hit myself like I
would go back home to AZ because I'm
from Phoenix and I would be like I would
always make an appointment
about me I promise like I want to go
take my kids to go see her bro that's
the [ __ ] that really means something to
me before I'm saying like I got a
one-year-old and a four-year-old
daughter you know what I'm saying like I
want to take all my kids my son four
years old you know of course you met
your son a bunch of times I need to go
take all my kids to go see her that's
what's important she want to see her
grandkids yeah so these are great great
and it'll make a great grandkid and
it'll make her life it'll make her
[ __ ] my grandma a soldier you know
what I'm saying so that's a lot like a
lot of [ __ ] that I battle wouldn't I be
dealing with bro and dealing with my
family and [ __ ] like I don't never
really say you know but I'm open to say
it now because I want people to
understand like I don't speak on this
[ __ ] so when you come to me with your
problems I got my own problem of course
I don't want to hear another [ __ ]
problems bro because I deal with my
problems head on and your problems
probably not even half of what I'm
dealing with and I got all the money I'm
dealing with More Money More Problems
but [ __ ] the money yeah I got my own
personal problems don't come to me about
no personal problems and I got these
problems in them problems you know what
I'm saying I'm telling you man you got
to go see your girl with a lot of [ __ ]
bro I definitely wanna I definitely have
to you know like I talk because I I've
been thinking in my head I'd be like
[ __ ] I wish I would have went and saw
her more I talked to my mom every day
about this [ __ ] you know talk to my dad
it's like I have to I don't I like right
now literally if I'm able to go visit my
old grandmother it just happened like
this a week recently yeah two weeks I
just got the window to go see yeah those
nursing homes they're being very careful
that [ __ ] wasn't like that bro I
couldn't see it right I'm just now able
to so I gotta take initiative right now
if I'm saying it that should be tough
it's crazy what you said about like not
being able to go see your grandma
because where she lived
exactly I just wonder how many like just
countless countless countless young men
are dealing with that same [ __ ] you know
I mean [ __ ] in Chicago can't go see
their grandmother Grand they mother
their kids because where they live you
know what I'm saying it that's why it's
so big on me to just bring opportunity
and change to the city you know what I'm
saying because if you don't bring no
opportunity [ __ ] is not beefing in
Chicago over money especially my
generation it ain't no money out there
[ __ ] Ain't beefing over no blocks or
drug lines and none of that [ __ ] [ __ ]
beefing over here say [ __ ] the
internet lack of money lack of
opportunities nothing to do but be angry
at everybody but once you start bringing
money on give a [ __ ]
and it's my opinion because I've
experienced money and I maybe I'm wrong
or maybe I'm not right but once you
start bringing money and opportunity to
[ __ ] Ain't nobody got time to do that
[ __ ] Bro once you got millions and you
can feed your family you don't want to
go do nothing no [ __ ] so if you're
doing that for this and for whoever like
you just bring an opportunity to Chicago
a lot of violence is gonna stop cause
[ __ ] Gonna Be able to take care of
their family if I'm saying like [ __ ]
could talk out differences or whatever
fight hit whatever you know I'm not
trying to end all the violence it's
impossible to never end all the violence
anywhere not just Chicago but like I'm
just trying to bring opportunity to the
youth so they don't have to do that so
even my generation we probably already
too [ __ ] up to be honest maybe I don't
know but definitely the newest
generation is I care about the youth I
care about the generations after me so
they don't got to live How I Live you
know what I'm saying that's what's
important to me I want my kids to live
highly bro I want my kids to have their
innocence to hide a youth what up y'all
we gotta stop the interview to tell you
about our new sponsors our family at
hardean Las Vegas you see what it is you
see what it is welcome to the family
heart Dean man we're so excited I've
been going to Hardy for so many years
for people who don't know Hardin is that
premium cannabis dispensary the number
one award-winning dispensary in Las
Vegas I'm talking the biggest and best
selection of cannabis product and of
course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're them [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to Jardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on the
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n Las vegas.com and don't
forget when you go to Vegas you go to
Jardin tell them I sent you and they're
gonna throw a little extra little eighth
in the bag or something a little
discount the bootleg discount you know
what I'm saying get them packwoods too
they give me a Packwood the other day
that geez I'm still recovering from that
[ __ ] blew my whole [ __ ] face off in
the best way Hardy in Las Vegas all
right shout out to them let's get back
to the interview what do you think is
specifically for Chicago
um
the key to Breaking the cycle and I know
that it's hard to talk about yeah I mean
it because I think that I think it
starts with like guys like yourself who
are leaders
um and I think you do a really good job
of
of not uh participating in stuff that I
see some of your other credit cards
participating in
um but I know that it's really it's
really hard
um to
to Once once people die once relatives
die or whatever I just I just I don't
know what it's like you know I think for
me at least from an outsider look in it
I think it starts with you know like you
said like if you're in a position to
give back if you're in a position to be
a positive influence on on on the
generation below you I think that's a
lot you know and and I do want to give
you props because
I feel like I never see
um you you wrapped up in negative
[ __ ] outside of you know hey you
know maybe you got a charge you're going
[ __ ] with your with your baby mama
whatever just dumb [ __ ] that you know
you're a famous person you're gonna deal
with it you're gonna deal with famous
person [ __ ] but I feel like
um you know I always say that like just
as an artist you've grown the most over
the years as a rapper you've you've
you've Leaps and Bounds lyrically but
all that [ __ ] aside like I feel like as
a man like you're one of those shining
examples of like you know um growth yeah
we saw you grow up in front of our eyes
and you know I want to just give you
kudos for not
participating in the [ __ ] [ __ ] that I
see a lot of people who you know are
your peers participating in but like
what do you think is the key to kind of
like
you're never going to stop everything
yeah for sure absolutely
um I think the key to it is opportunity
bro yeah people who are opportunists so
at the end of the day if you were
opportunist and I'm not I may give you
opportunity because as an opportunist
you may think all right the way to feed
my family is to do this on the Internet
or do this or yeah because [ __ ] [ __ ] if
you don't get into the [ __ ] [ __ ] you see
you see your metrics the [ __ ] [ __ ] is
what's feeding people family but at the
end of the day it's what's in their
families as well 100 that [ __ ] is
feeding families and and their families
at the same time and it's the short nut
it's like yeah short you feel and I I
feel like for what I don't wanna because
I could I could feed into all the [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I could be on [ __ ] [ __ ]
but I'm not for what I feel like I got
so much to lose and that's just from
experiencing life on so many ways bro
because I used to wake up every day on
[ __ ] [ __ ]
but I ain't on that bro I wake up every
day in a big ass crib right with my kids
I don't even want to think about no [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying and it's
like at the end of the day it's so easy
to like snap back and like entertain
goofy [ __ ] or whatever but I feel like
the key component to internet is
opportunity bro you got to get a nigga's
opportunity and you gotta understand you
gotta be understanding of why [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] it's certain [ __ ] on
[ __ ] [ __ ] they don't have nothing else
to resort to but that they don't have no
other opportunities no ways of making
money they in they Hood all day where
it's nothing but negativity I could tell
you every day it was nothing but
negativity in my neighborhood every day
is some function going on it's the only
thing we still finding ways to smile
yeah to have fun my friends my best
friends dad I'm coming back on this
block every day and I'm still able to
crack a smile which is crazy that's
insane that's insane yeah if I'm saying
so to understand that is one of the main
reasons why I don't feed into it because
I understand I get why [ __ ] frustrated
I could get why a [ __ ] may be
frustrated even at me because I'm able
to live on this side of the fence that's
survivor's remorse and that's why I
understand like damn it's cool I know
you're going through this I really want
to help you
but I gotta be able to help you but you
gotta want to help yourself you gotta
want to help yourself but it's like
[ __ ] certain [ __ ] can't even help
they self because they in this
environment it's hard to want to help
yourself be when you enter you're just
trying to survive every day that's the
Survivor side I survived this [ __ ] so I
understand it different you know what
I'm saying like everything just tied
back into each other and it's like that
[ __ ] tough bro and I understand it
because I once come from that if I'm
saying so the reason why I don't feed
into it is because it ain't even worth
it to me well that takes a lot of
humility on your behalf to be like you
know what I'm not feeding into this [ __ ]
because I get it I was there I get it
yeah I get it if I'm saying like I was
once you I relate to you so I feel like
with me being an open book and being
vulnerable about this [ __ ] a [ __ ] would
be like damn he really do get it right
[ __ ] it let me just change everything
because I made the biggest sacrifice I
wouldn't be here today if I ain't say
[ __ ] everything bro and every [ __ ]
around me could contest to it I said
[ __ ] everything [ __ ] being on the Block
[ __ ] hanging with my friends [ __ ] rap I
said [ __ ] everything let me just get my
mind right bro I stay in my mama house
literally [ __ ] I had a condo downtown
when I was 17 years old bro I stayed in
my mama house in my 20s and just stayed
in the basement and just trying to like
think about life Bro think about where I
would be if I made certain decisions if
I'm saying if I was still outside
hanging on my block because I love my
hood so much but I got millions of
dollars if I'm saying I'm making
millions of dollars you know and that
was one of the toughest times I ever
been through in my life yeah people who
experience that with me know I went
through some tough [ __ ] and I overcame
that so I'm saying all that to say is no
matter what you're going through in your
life or whatever tough times you're
going through you could just buckle down
embrace it and overcome it you know I'm
saying this people going through tougher
[ __ ] than me of course so you just gotta
take it for what it is bro and just try
to be the best version of yourself that
you could be tomorrow than you was
yesterday and you keep trying to do that
and then you look up [ __ ] two months
then going back you're like damn I think
totally different right I can get back
out here and just do my thing you feel
me I think I was gonna say I think
another thing that you probably I think
that we have to stop romanticizing the
wrong [ __ ] yeah like if you come from a
certain area
like at the end of the day unless you
own that real estate [ __ ] ain't about
nothing it ain't about nothing I don't
know yo man who cares like like who like
I I one of my biggest pet peeves is when
I see people like I'm still here y'all
can't come over here and I'm like yo
like at the end of the day like you grew
up there and and and you know where you
grew up like your goal should be to try
to evolve and get into a different
situation out of here so we can own this
[ __ ] you know what I'm saying involve
and show you this and that's crazy you
saying that bro this like
some of the deepest [ __ ] I've been
talking about right now with you because
I just did the AZ on the Block ship in
Chicago right there I just did the AJ on
the Block interview I thought about I'm
like I'm gonna go back to the block and
shoot this [ __ ] and I thought like I
don't own that [ __ ] gang I own a school
in Chicago I'm gonna shoot my [ __ ] right
here you on the school I own the school
why would you shoot on the blocks at the
school that's when I'm gonna shoot right
here
right here my [ __ ] I own this property
gang
I own this [ __ ] bro why not want to
shoot right here why not want to shoot
right here why not go back to the block
when I could own this [ __ ] and get this
[ __ ] to people who I care about how my
home and you got a uh a development
company a construction company a Paint
Company Real Estate Management Company
get that [ __ ] to y'all and now we really
on the Block post up on that [ __ ] all
y'all want let's do this that's what I'm
on also like your goal should always be
to get back to your kids every day hell
yeah and if it's like a three percent
chance to something wrong happens when
you go shoot that if it's a two percent
chance one percent chance don't do it
let me minimize yeah man I need to
maximize the chance to be getting home
to my kids [ __ ] I'm up suing some [ __ ]
rub me the wrong way I ain't doing it
you know what I'm saying but I was the
same [ __ ] like I know for a fact I know
every risk of doing this I'ma still do
it right because I feel like all right
bet I could do it yeah cause I got that
same like my my man had work I know I
feel like I could overcome any situation
and that's dangerous so I'll put myself
and it's [ __ ] up situation and that's
also not like I could overcome no that's
a terrible myself wait a crazy way to
think well I learned that way to think
in bad circumstances I feel like I used
to be the same way where I'd be like no
we're gonna be all right we're gonna be
straight we're gonna get through
whatever happens I got it [ __ ] it we got
it until you don't until you don't
everything all good till it ain't until
it ain't nobody's bulletproof nobody is
uh everything all good until it ain't
bro no that's some real [ __ ] and I think
a lot of people need to stop moving
around with um
just like I feel like false privilege
like hey man you ain't no better than
anybody else you know what I'm saying
and I know that though I understand that
if I'm saying I just felt like I was the
best version of myself right
and that ain't no way to think no I
think um I think man I just you know
salute to you dog because I swear man I
always tell people that in interviews
whenever your name is brought up I'm
like man you're like I think like a
beaming light from a city that needs
that light you know what I'm saying and
I think um
you know just to watch you I think the
first time I saw you I was on the side
of the stage at Summer Jam when Nikki
brought you out yeah that's crazy so
that was like 2014 or 15. was that 14
2014 for sure how old were you 2014 I
was 17. so that was yeah I remember that
[ __ ] like that was like that was one of
them days 14 17 18 some [ __ ] like that
yeah that was one of those days I always
remember because we were right there
like we bullshitted our way where the
label didn't kick us out and I'm like
standing there watching [ __ ] Nikki
and Drake yeah and you get brought out
that was a that was how big of how
pivotal of like a day was that for you
to get brought out of Summer Jam by
Nikki man that [ __ ] was crazy bro I was
so nervous I couldn't even really like
because you got to understand bro I'm
coming from
say knife every day that's why I'm
hanging it like literally I'm right
there the day before I fly out the
ground so it's like I didn't even feel
like I belonged there right I feel like
I felt I'll Blended in better over there
and that's the wrong way to think cause
I've been a superstar [ __ ] I wouldn't
even been there if I ain't belong with
them of course Nikki would have never
reached out to me if I didn't deserve to
be there but when I come around that I
feel like I was out of place that's
[ __ ] crazy I should have felt like I
was out of place on my block right you
feel me I felt the most comfortable over
there and when I get around Wayne
[ __ ] baby Nikki all these Superstars
me this is my first time really meeting
all of them right I ain't say a word
yeah
bro Drake [ __ ] I swear to God Drake
could contest to this right now yeah we
backstage
my first real encounter with Drake was
y'all don't know who this is this is my
favorite rapper Drake called me his
favorite rapper [ __ ] when I was 18
years it's my favorite rapper right now
and I got so shy I'm like man what the
[ __ ] you just put me on the spot like
that for it [ __ ] me up because I felt
out of place already being there I
didn't feel like a stop you feel I
didn't know how to feel like a stock
cause I'm up against this [ __ ] you're up
against real life I'm up against real
life yeah I didn't feel like a star bro
so for Drake to tell me that right then
I didn't even know how to feel it made
me so [ __ ] uncomfortable that he did
that you feel me and that's probably why
like our relationship ain't with should
be today because I didn't Embrace him
telling me that yeah I didn't know how
to feel when he told me that [ __ ] bro I
swear to God a [ __ ] told me in front of
baby Wayne Nikki G robot that night that
night backstage he said I don't know
what this is cause I'm in the corner I
ain't talking to nobody right right
right I don't know this is man this this
is my favorite rapper man right now I'll
[ __ ] with Shorty and I ain't know what
to think I still was nervous when I went
out on stage you feel me like yeah and
I'm saying all that to say for any
artist or anybody that's trying to do
this [ __ ] like embrace your inner stock
embrace your power because this [ __ ]
could be taken from you any day and I'm
blessed that God didn't take this [ __ ]
from me when I took it for granted or
when I didn't understand what it was and
that's why I'm here today you know what
I'm saying so that [ __ ] crazy to me bro
it's crazy and that full circle you came
out of rolling glasses came out rolling
loud with Nikki you know what I'm saying
like full circle to this day me and Dre
cool that's my brother yeah I talked to
him all the time you know what I'm
saying like I was will you be hooping
together and [ __ ] now you feel me we go
hang out and all this [ __ ] you know like
so it's just like a different horror
that I have about myself because I'm
mature and I'm a different person yeah
what would you say is the main component
for you to
have the longevity because I mean listen
man we're talking going on 10 years now
right so like a lot of people's I mean
careers last a summer
two years you know like like I mean we
don't even gotta say names on the top of
your head this goes on so many artists
and I'm like damn y'all had you had a
high year yeah and then you're like what
happened you know what I mean like what
do you think is uh been pertinent to you
staying relevant and and you know for me
I think just from a fan of is growth
yeah the growth musically is being
myself yes embracing my flaws bro not
feeling like I supposed to be that [ __ ]
oh I support you know because you're not
wearing like a rapper costume either I'm
not a random rapper costume I'm being
myself you know what I'm saying at the
end of the day as before our mature and
became this person you will look look at
them still in the hood I'm doing all
this [ __ ] and I'm like how the [ __ ] is
this [ __ ] doing better than me and I
know for a fact I ain't a competitive
person I don't compare nobody which is
important you know because that is a
flaw that's a flaw I never look at
nobody it's like I'm supposed to be
where they at yeah you would look at a
[ __ ] and be like I'm supposed to be
where he at now and then next year where
is he and you still doing this I ain't
never did this I never shout out once
you start looking over him I always did
this and this and this and this and this
because I always bet it on myself you
know I always believed in myself and I
always been myself bro every every uh
all through my career I'm going through
something personally you know what I'm
saying what is adversity red is the
music industry ready is fighting the
case whether it's dealing with some [ __ ]
at home I just find a way to just be the
best version of myself when I'm out here
being G herbal right because I'm not g
herbo Herbert right right G herbo is the
basically the costume but I don't put on
a rapper costume I'm not trying to BG
herbo because I am G herbo that's me
automatically I am that but at the end
of the day I'm a man bro and that's
what's important to me so I always
focused on being that and just being the
best man I could be as long as I'm the
best man I could be I'm gonna always be
the best rap I could be that [ __ ] easy
bro I ain't no rap I'm a solid [ __ ] you
see what I'm saying it that's what's
important to me and that's what people
gravitate to you know what I'm saying so
a lot of times people didn't really
catch on to the rap I ain't had no
plaques and all this crazy [ __ ] going on
you know what I'm saying I'm just not
really getting my plaques now I'm
getting my flowers now but I ain't never
asked for them I ain't one of them the
people who [ __ ] with me [ __ ] me if
it was for you it's for you
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture out of my guy
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you 200 on top of that to gamble
with for free if you put in a thousand
dollars they're gonna match that deposit
with a free thousand dollars for you to
gamble with right now so what the [ __ ]
are you waiting for let's get this money
let's watch some [ __ ] football and
let's get paid with my bookie well you
know what it is a lot of people use that
kind of [ __ ] as a way to give them like
like feel like
they look at accolades relationships
props from other artists as like a way
to validate themselves validate
themselves and it's like bro like if you
know you're straight and you know you're
on your mission like everything will
come like at the end of the day I always
knew I was sorry you can't let outside
[ __ ] validate who you are and
unfortunately like a lot of people
that's I mean I've been I've been in
that position in my life where I was so
worried about what everybody thought or
I have two you are always going to be in
that position you worry about what
everybody thinks but the thing that made
me stop caring is
it was always because of the internet if
I'm saying like the people that I deal
with on the day-to-day where there's
somebody I work with some my first time
meeting somebody My Mother My Girl my
kids right my girl mother family
everybody love me when they meet me and
I started to think like I mean I'm a
solid [ __ ] I ain't never really had
nobody really say nothing bad about me
like in the streets my name always been
good even in the music industry in the
music industry as you know it's fake as
[ __ ] yeah I don't know anybody who's
ever said anything bad about you my name
good I'll help you bro cause I just
focus on being a solid dude right
personally my name good and the industry
my name good so it's like I can't really
care about what nobody said about me
because I ain't perfect I'm gonna [ __ ]
up of course so if I embrace my flaws
and just try to be the best version of
myself I'ma always be good and that's
why I never fed into like internet [ __ ]
cooking my name's solid bro would always
been solid no matter what I did whether
I was in the streets every day in the
industry at home my name always been
solid with my flaws with every [ __ ] up I
ever had in my life my name still always
remains solid and that's what's
important to me that's all I really care
about that's important man and I also
think too like you've done a good job of
navigating the internet era which which
was not necessarily
present like it is now when you first
got into it it definitely was hell no
the internet presence was never like
what it is now like nobody never when I
first started doing music even though
the internet was Instagram Myspace all
that nobody never really felt
comfortably walking up on those Street
[ __ ] when they phone out or that's a
No-No automatically like people not even
scared like that imma do something to
them smack they phone out there I never
done it I swear my whole career can't
nobody never say I smacked they phone
out the hand I just embrace it like damn
you know I could be sleep man or having
a bad day I'm just like damn you know I
either watch out or I'm gonna break your
family right that was never cool it
ain't never been cool to walk up on
nobody with your phone I'll be having my
kids I could have my brand new baby
walking through the airport [ __ ]
walk I'm gonna do like that it's crazy
that's crazy to me bro and that's not
cool we need to not normalize that [ __ ]
bro yeah we got to get people to
normalize that give people their space
yeah at the end of the day because we
all human how would you feel if you're a
regular person and your kid just
in your arms and they like the kids
shoes or people Negative they may think
your kid looks funny I try to crack a
joke yeah I've had that happen where
I've been at the grocery store when I
had a my son was a baby and they'd be
like I've had people try to be like oh
your baby's so cute and go to touch her
I'm like don't touch my [ __ ] man I
ain't with that you feel I'm saying like
people would try to like used to try to
like when my girl was pregnant they used
to always try to touch her stomach and
I'll be knocked back don't do that do
that I don't know you I ain't with that
are you the grandma are you the Auntie
[ __ ] out of here don't bring that [ __ ]
you feel me but people feel welcome
enough to do that and then I'm the bag
at oh her push me I try that's my baby
right here I don't know what the [ __ ]
you into ah really do something to you
you trying to touch my girl's stomach
while she pregnant you feel me but at
the end of the day we all human so you
gotta understand that bro you got to
really understand where a [ __ ] come
from when he do 100 man 100 I want to
ask you this because I think um you know
one of the main components that kind of
uh people when they think about early
Chicago days we as and not early Chicago
in general because you know we can go
back to like Twista and common and all
that [ __ ] but like in terms of just the
drill movement
um
You Know Chief Keef obviously kicked the
door down
uh I saw you talk about kind of his
influence and what um Charlemagne said
yeah and you're going to see Charlemagne
this weekend shout out to my guy
um I I wonder I know some people had
felt a certain type of way about when
academics was doing the war in Chiraq
[ __ ] around that time you were probably
a lot more present in some of that [ __ ]
yeah was that something that you guys
paid attention to or oh yeah was it
something you saw added to the violence
yeah it definitely added to the violence
and I'll I got a one-on-one academics
too and we could talk about this you
know what I'm saying Academy's my
brother I'll [ __ ] with him you know what
I'm saying um but we thought academics
was from Chicago
thank you so much yeah yeah he ain't
from Chicago bro right he's speaking on
this [ __ ] in a way where it's like
Jersey got a hood Jersey got a trenches
Jersey got rappers all this you're not
speaking on this [ __ ] because you from
there these people really know you right
I feel like in my opinion you know
you're not gonna speak so much on what's
going on in Jersey even though Chicago
had the bigger Spotlight on him and it
was something to talk about but at the
end of the day you don't know how many
people lost their lives outside of the
internet about some [ __ ] you talk about
right you calling a [ __ ] you calling
Reese the Grim Reaper like a [ __ ] I
want to kill him just because you call
him to say yeah you call a [ __ ] the
Grim Reaper [ __ ] the Grim Reaper you
don't supposed to call no man the Grim
Reaper you feel I'm saying the Grim
Reaper is a representation of death
and you calling this man that they got a
family they got kids they got a mother
they got a sister that people got but he
was young I gave him that I give him
credit he was just on the outside
looking in and it was something to talk
about and it built his platform to this
day I'm not gonna knock him for that
right but at the end of the day a lot of
that [ __ ] made a big difference in
what's going on now I promise you we
didn't know who academics was we thought
academics was from Chicago yeah because
he knew so much but that's somebody that
was just in tune with what we doing
because we broadcasted it so we got to
hold ourselves accountable right talking
about it in the music exactly we
broadcasted this [ __ ] so I'm gonna be a
man and say yeah we started it for sure
right we initiated it but at the end of
the day we was just kids and this was
all reality right we didn't ever look at
this [ __ ] like oh we put these guns on
internet we gonna get famous it was just
cameras we were just cameras around
videos [ __ ] started rapping we just
embracing our life as soon as that
camera went down we ain't put them guns
in storage right [ __ ] was right
on the block with us and we protecting
our life
that's what we was up against and people
got to understand that and a lot of
people lost their life to that and
that's a lot of reasons why people react
and behave the way they do you know what
I'm saying yeah I think I understand
like the uh because I know Vic uh shout
out to Vic uh Vic Mentor like he he was
not I mean I know a lot of people who
have you know negative connotations
towards academics rightfully so a lot of
people do but I think at that time I I
don't know if he understood the gravity
of what he was doing I will give him I
will give him the benefit to say he
didn't understand what he was doing and
at that time I'm not sure he ever knew
he'd be
on camera yeah like we know academics is
like a personality in hip-hop as to
where like then he was just the voice
that was just you know kind of narrating
on camera about yeah nobody knew how he
looked when he was doing that he didn't
show his face right and I think that's
one of the reasons why he didn't he
didn't want nobody to know how he looked
right he didn't want nobody know who he
was because the [ __ ] he was doing bro
yeah I ain't gonna lie and you gotta I'm
gonna talk I'm gonna talk to him when we
say that for real like you gotta really
hold yourself accountable for what
you've done and the same responsible for
a lot of this [ __ ] the same way that we
are as artists I think that's important
is the I think I think
ha anybody who's a grown ass man look
man if you were 19 20 making YouTube
videos you should at least own whatever
you want to own it I was 19 20 and you
I'm talking about the [ __ ] I'm up
against or 18 17 but I wasn't talking
about nothing and if I want somebody to
go outside and kill somebody and even
I'm talking about some [ __ ] cause I just
seen my best friend get his [ __ ] head
blown up it's crazy even just the
influence of like those videos like
because now there's so many YouTube
channels and their whole stick is
talking over
clips that we don't know what these
people look like we just know that
they're covering whatever City's
[ __ ] that's going on like it'd be
hard for me to touch on it because it's
so close to home of course man the
sensitive subject you feel I'm saying
like I lost a lot of people that I
really love it's crazy I mean like you
said it's behind the streets bro you
feel me what is your opinion on
when you come from a place like Chicago
where
a lot of conflict is rooted from a very
real place
um I feel like the last few years we've
seen
hip-hop beef
people who aren't from the same place
not even anyone specifically exactly but
people who aren't even from the same
state people who do not grow up around
each other have serious beef that is
equal Bloodshed life being lost like to
me it's like a shame when I see that
[ __ ] it's like really and a lot of it is
the internet the IG the Twitter all this
[ __ ] but like you know I just feel like
um uh we got to figure out a way to try
to nip that kind of [ __ ] in the butt
like if someone's from the same place
and they got cool it's not even cool
I'm not cool understandable but the rap
beef [ __ ] I'm like man especially if
it's from people who come from a place
where they know what beef is it's like
what's the point of like having like a
real beef with another rapper who's not
even from where you're from exactly I
feel like it's unnecessary and and
anyway you know what I'm saying it
that's why I try to like stay in my Lane
because I unders I understand it I get
it I get why people have differences and
they think like oh I just react this way
and maybe sometimes they go straight to
the internet which make it even more
bigger because yeah they not from the
same state that's the only form of
communication at that point so it's like
you making [ __ ] bigger than what it is
instead of just getting on the phone a
lot of [ __ ] avoid getting on the phone
a lot of [ __ ] avoid being accountable
for their actions a lot of [ __ ] scared
to get on that phone and say damn I bet
this is what it is this is the
misunderstanding or maybe we should link
right here and we could
settle it you know a lot of [ __ ] get
on that internet and it's like
and it [ __ ] could be something as simple
as a phone call two [ __ ] getting on
the phone that don't nobody know so easy
nobody nobody even need to know the
nature of the conversation but when you
go on the internet and you saying
something about this [ __ ] you don't
know it's a hundred other [ __ ] that
love him oh so you know what probably
not even on that but a hundred other
[ __ ] that love him now you can't even
do a show in this city you can't do this
you can't do that and they become real
beef when y'all ain't from the city and
it ain't no blood [ __ ] it become
[ __ ] over Pride over some internet
and you know what I think some people
are scared to get on the phone because
they're afraid of this internet [ __ ]
but at the end of the day it's like if
you confident as a man
if you on the phone saying some sucker
[ __ ] then that's your problem that's
your problem yeah if you're on the
internet seeing [ __ ] I'm listening did
you get on the phone and say some sucker
[ __ ] you deserve to get recorded right
right right right right but if you're on
the phone being a man and being solid
yeah it ain't even that serious bro I
feel like you did this I did this [ __ ]
it it's cool bro it ain't even no thing
I don't feel like less of a man because
everybody's in the same cities you end
up in L.A you end up in Atlanta
you know what I'm saying I want to have
those uh allies with people if I go to
Atlanta I need to be able to call
somebody in Atlanta that I [ __ ] with if
I'm straight and I even got nothing to
do with no Street [ __ ] if I'm stranded I
need hey it's good to go to this
restaurant right here no it ain't you
know what I'm saying L.A St Louis New
Orleans whatever I'm at vice versa bro
you gotta build especially being an
artist it's like ain't no such thing as
being on your own I don't believe in
that bro I feel like we all stronger
together period so I don't believe in
that rap dishes never rap this [ __ ]
from my city right I definitely ain't
gonna rap beef with a [ __ ] from another
city what the [ __ ] I'm doing that for
the more gangster [ __ ] is to get on the
phone get on the phone get on the phone
that's the real gangster [ __ ] though all
that internet the gangster [ __ ] get on
the phone talk to it what's up what's
going on bro what's the word we good all
right it's cool it's cool or if it
really is a difference let's link up and
solve it or if it's going whatever it's
gonna be keep it off the internet let's
do this amongst men so at the end of the
day I have family safe uh friends safe
our name safe our brand our career is
safe we could continue getting as much
let's just talk about this [ __ ] as men
and that's what we missed right I want
to dive into the tracklist for the album
but first I need to take a piss uh piss
break hey what up y'all it's bootleg cab
here to stop the interview sorry uh but
we gotta pay the [ __ ] bills and you
know not only do we have to pay the
bills but we also gotta take care of
them [ __ ] out there that's right make
sure you go to bluetooth.com right now
you know the bootleg kept podcast we are
presented by bluetooth proudly I happen
to every once in a while dabbling a
little you know what I'm saying and let
me tell you something my dick thanks me
for it every single time uh so listen if
you go to Bluetooth use the promo code
bootleg you're gonna get your first
month supply for free now we're talking
the same active ingredient as Viagra as
Cialis without the awkward doctor's
appointment visit you just go online
they get you taken care of it gets
delivered right to your [ __ ] door and
discreet packaging it's a beautiful
thing and how about this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and staxin
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground rap
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue chair you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole some all night
long bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg right now and they will give you
the first month for free so go do that
[ __ ]
all right fresh off the piss break we
should take one more shot real quick
let's do a shot we'll take us a shot man
you see I know I'll be having I sip the
repo I'm I'll take a shot of the blanco
real quick got the repo on the top side
man
man she made me this way
to Tequila man
the pandemic drink
all these tequila brands oh [ __ ]
cover 19.
if kova 19 Migos owe me a check first
and foremost
check in before I check out man
we got about 10 days to respond you know
um you know who's that's what that's
George Clooney's uh tequila yeah he sold
it he sold it actually did he yeah he
sold it [ __ ] good for it cashed out as
he should yeah yeah as he should cash
out uh this album you uh you did the two
side two if if it was [ __ ] 2006 it'd
be a double disc right yeah so it's a
double album uh what was the motivation
behind doing that because I don't feel
like we see that a lot anymore yeah I it
took for me to
really get out here and hear from other
people that it's like people haven't
really been doing this [ __ ] but my whole
inspiration behind the double album was
where I put so much like time and effort
into the music and what I'm trying to
the message I'm trying to get across
behind survivor's March you know like
the [ __ ] that I'm talking about on the
interviews is deep I can't really talk
about through my music like right you
know I'm saying rappers don't really do
like
and a lose and skits and [ __ ] no more
you know what I'm saying but I really do
want to get back to that to be honest I
want to get back to skits and [ __ ] so
when y'all start doing all that [ __ ] man
don't be trying to bite my sauce you
know what I'm saying but anyways I feel
the whole point of me doing that was
to create that
that that that
atmosphere of the Survivor side the
Triumph side you know I'm saying like
it's a it's Triumph for me when I wake
up and I'm able to get into all my cars
and you know I'm saying to be able like
through all my career I never really
blended with my peers musically like
I've been knowing future I've been
[ __ ] future future and been on my own
on the hood game I didn't put up on
future on 73rd and Kingston oh [ __ ] 30
feet away from my grandma house that I'm
saying I can't even go right there right
you feel I'm saying I didn't put up on
future right there before he'd have been
in my hood I've been [ __ ] with future
you know what I'm saying like I've been
[ __ ] with
Meeks and been having me and Kodak was
on the freshman cover together that's
our first song ever doing together
legendary cover I've been having all
like interactions with offsets and hey
boogie that's my brother we he been on
been on two three of my albums you know
what I'm saying like but I'm saying I'll
let to say
like I never embraced my true
rapper stardom or me being G herboing
people [ __ ] them I know they [ __ ] with
me because I'm around them right I'm in
the studio with these [ __ ] building
relationships I never really told nobody
get on the song or none of that you know
what I'm saying but at the end of the
day I know they [ __ ] me I could have
always like make a tell you throughout
my career he always like bro go get
songs from these [ __ ] do songs I'm
telling them like yeah [ __ ] I was just
in the store bro what you was on
insulation I'm in the studio with Pluto
I was in Stuart Thug with me we chilling
like I ain't getting no song I'm like
sure I ain't asking for no song to be
honest but you know what that's what
that's also awesome that's why people
[ __ ] with you because it's a genuine
friendship it's not something I'm just
trying to [ __ ] with [ __ ] and Vibe out
because at the end of the day I know I'm
good I'm building my [ __ ] yeah for sure
for sure when they come to me building
my own I'm gonna do that and I ain't
never really asked nobody to help me do
that you know what I'm saying like so
for me to do the Survivor side is really
like a moment of Triumph like I feel
like now I'm able to do that because my
thought process is different like
sometimes I just want to be around
[ __ ] and get inspiration because I
gotta go right back to the trenches
after this yep now that I'm living life
a little differently I feel like it's
easy for me to interact with my peers a
little differently you know what I'm
saying so that was the Survivor side of
it just me and like embracing the fact
that I am that [ __ ] I am G herbo you
feel I'm saying I could get in the
studio with the best of them and I could
hold my own weight or I could be around
the best of them and like I'm really
having my way for real you feel I got
cribs in La cars I got all the [ __ ] to
just you know what I'm saying talk about
I never really talked about that [ __ ]
you feel me that's crazy that that's uh
the first record you have a Kodak yeah
and we was freshman covers the on the
freshman cover together and I [ __ ] with
Kodak shout out to bro I'm saying like
when we really like connected on some
man-to-man [ __ ] I [ __ ] with him he a
good [ __ ] you know um and you know the
remorse out of it is me understanding
everything that I come from there were
more sad and knowing like that's the
reason that the remote side is the
reason why I never really embraced going
to hang with other artists so I never
flexed the fact that I always had a nice
ass condo downtown I always had jury I
always had money I was always able to
afford this [ __ ] I didn't really brag
about it because it's people that I
really care about that can't afford that
luxury and I was thinking for them for a
long time but at the end of the day I
realized I got to think for myself and I
could never help anybody unless I think
for myself because I'm the leader I'm
the prize I'm the one that's gonna go
out and go get all the money and make
this [ __ ] bigger than life so I gotta
think for myself and sometimes it sounds
selfish but it's not because I know I'm
not a selfish person I know for a fact
I'ma always look out for my people right
right right but I gotta think for myself
first and that's the remorse that
understanding that damn I wasted so much
time thinking about the wrong [ __ ] when
I really should have just been thinking
about myself the whole time and this
[ __ ] would have probably been 10 has
bigger right this date right you feel me
and that survive as a mortgage that's
why I did a double-sided album because
everything I lost along the way I always
been able to talk about it I always
talked about it but people don't see
like I didn't have a conversation with
my man it's my homie little he from New
Orleans he like bro you don't show [ __ ]
like you don't show when you buy new
cars you know I'm showing you about
jewelry you know you got money on you
you don't show none of that because it
don't excite me it ain't nothing that I
feel like I need to show it ain't for
nobody to see unless something to show
you how to get this [ __ ] yeah I mean
it's not I think that's I think that's a
positive that you that you know so
positive I just think like that but at
the end of the day I feel like I never
did that because I always feel like if
you don't think I got this [ __ ] you
stupid you ain't paying attention you
don't think I'm really having my way out
here you really [ __ ] done I gotta put
it in your face for real I think that's
why you're fans talking with you though
like ain't no point of me putting this
in your face you know what I'm saying I
could you know but well I don't get none
from it so it's like who am I doing it
for me all you get free [ __ ] don't
satisfy me certain people are really
satisfied like
so it's like
that survive was remorse for me you know
to be able to to be on both sides of the
playing field bro I still got people who
I love that's in the trenches bro my
grandma died in the trenches I could
have been moved her my grandma I was
into that type of [ __ ] my grandma could
have been living in whatever the [ __ ]
she went through I would have moved her
before my mama I'll make my mama live
with my grandma Yeah you feel me okay
I'll just get a big trip together
exactly but my grandma wouldn't know
that she told me before I ever had any
money she said I'm dying on Kingston wow
she meant that [ __ ] she said I'm dying
right here on this block I'm not moving
right you feel me and I got aunties and
all type of cousins and [ __ ] that's
still in the trenches that don't want
that though they want to get out yeah so
them the people who I care about my
friends and [ __ ] like that you know what
I'm saying but it's just it's hard being
on both you know being on both sides of
the field where you like you a leader
here in the leader there you know what
I'm saying where it's like I'm the
leader of my household I'm the leader
everybody that really depend on me and
not even the leader like in the trenches
or the streets I'm the leader because
I'm the The Vessel the person that they
looking at like damn he could really
change our situation you feel me but I
can only I feel the more I elevated the
more I like learn life I can only
provide somebody opportunity talk about
uh the school that you own yeah because
I think that's dope I mean
um
school I partner you know me and my
partners we go to school it's in Chicago
right yeah on the south side yeah on the
south side of Chicago like in the heart
you know what I'm saying and that was
just something that you know I was like
I was hands on don't get me wrong but it
was just like a good idea then when
they're like all right but invest in
this [ __ ] you know what I'm saying and
we got to school but it was important
to me because I come from youth centers
I come from you know Sandy six and
Phillips cyc you know my auntie my aunt
um my aunt Micheline she enrolled me in
the center when I was a kid to just get
me out of trouble
only a JT that was like a father figure
for me growing up and he died like the
worst of the worst kids in the
neighborhood like not worse but like
right we wasn't bad kids we was just
troubled kids who was uh in poverty and
on a certain circumstance we wasn't bad
kids bro if we would have stayed in that
[ __ ] and we had somebody like myself
Derrick Rose or Kanye or somebody
whoever yeah whoever the [ __ ] it could
have been to come right here and show us
like hell no we finna give you all the
resources to be great I guarantee you a
lot of us would have came out
millionaires by the way this lawyers
artists NBA players when that [ __ ] got
taken away from us a lot of us Dad yeah
a lot of us went to jail a lot of us
just turned to the streets you feel I'm
saying so I believe in that my first
time ever going to an NBA game ever
going out of this [ __ ] to some
account was through that Center so
that's why I invested in the school to
turn that into that for the positive
Place something a place for people to
get out of the streets and to find a
trade like right we're gonna put a
studio in there we're gonna have arts in
there you're gonna have culinary in
there we're going to have uh [ __ ]
um what's it called coding computer code
that's just important like videography
whatever you want to do I don't care if
we don't even got a room for whatever
you want to do if you those are
practical trades we're gonna put the
Practical trade resource engineering
because not everybody could be the
rapper not everybody
come if I call and say hey man I need
you to come teach these kids right
whether I pay you or what are you doing
off the love [ __ ] [ __ ] with me right
somebody gonna come and show these some
tangible like I'm in the hood all the
time I don't know I don't brag on it I
don't record I'm in Chicago but I'm
there all the time and I let people see
me I let kids see me because I'm
something that's they look get as
influence a role model but they don't
have to look from on the internet they
don't got to see me back they see you in
person and be like damn I want a car
[ __ ] I don't even know how to get this
[ __ ] I'm a rob you feel me right no you
don't got to do that I'm gonna show you
how to get this [ __ ] [ __ ] I'll show you
how to make cars build cars right
whatever you want to do I'm gonna put it
right here for you so you can have your
innocence so you can keep your charisma
so you could build your talent build a
trade and be the best you you could be
that's what's important for me because
if it wasn't for rap if it wasn't for me
just being chosen by God I'd be dead on
jail bro I thought is the reason why I'm
here right now we gotta think about too
like um
you know
not just in bad neighborhoods but just
period like I think like trade schools
got to be more prevalent because like
think about it like bro bro first of all
you go to college [ __ ] a deep subject
bro I could talk about that [ __ ] make me
I feel it in my chest when I talk about
because think about this like if you go
to college for some [ __ ] degree that
you end up racking up a quarter of a
million dollars in student debt and then
you're making 80 grand a year entry
level it's like wouldn't like what did
you do it's in the more practical thing
to be like I want to be a graphic
designer I want to be an electrician I
want like these are things that like you
know are like
don't take as much bandwidth don't put
you in a financially [ __ ] place and
like not everyone's bill for college
guess what we'd be pushing this college
[ __ ] because it's big business you're
not and it's like the certain it's like
what having somebody like myself or
having the resources where you want to
be an electrician you want to be uh
somebody had their own a barber a
construction a contractor or whatever
yeah you could be a barber that really
because you you build your brand so much
now you a a million dollars yeah now you
own 10 [ __ ] million dollar [ __ ] you
wanna just learning how to capitalize
off this [ __ ] bro by the time you 35 you
a million dollar [ __ ] you got 20 barber
shops yep I'm 27 years old if I would
have did anything else the same way that
I would have been able to chase rap and
Chase my dreams and just be better and
better and better and better every year
I would have been a millionaire
regardless because I got this you got it
in you yeah
you've been a millionaire whatever the
[ __ ] I did you know what I'm saying but
now I choose this I'm gonna be a
billionaire I'm gonna have a hundred
million out this [ __ ] yeah man so with
me being that I could spread it I could
make 10 15 millionaires
of the muscle just huh you can have this
[ __ ] it ain't gonna take nothing for me
I'm already good I promise I'm good I
ain't gonna never have to do [ __ ] my
kids ain't gonna never have to do [ __ ] I
ain't gonna have to go back to the hood
nothing right now and it's I think so I
stopped rapping them all yeah good I
promise I'm gonna be great my kids gonna
be great everybody gonna be great I
think I said why would I stop yeah it's
important too because I can help y'all
get this [ __ ] yeah I was gonna say most
people don't most people don't have that
mind State they don't want to share the
wealth you know what I mean the fact
you're passionate about that is is is is
great because you know if more people
are passionate about that like you said
imagine if there was 30 of you in
Chicago instead of just you or it's just
you and whoever I know talk about it you
know what I'm saying because it can be
who else I know there are other artists
in Chicago that are helping yeah chance
do a lot of [ __ ] Dirk do a lot of [ __ ]
behind the scene Polo do a lot of [ __ ]
you feel I'm saying but it need to be
broadcasted we need to come together and
do this [ __ ] see that's the kind of [ __ ]
that should make blogs we should do some
[ __ ] [ __ ] it like I'm gonna say it here
we should do a show a big ass show me
Dirk chance Polo [ __ ] Bibby Keith
everybody come back to the United Center
do a big ass show and give all the
proceeds to Lori Lightfoot and give that
[ __ ] to all the schools get that [ __ ] to
the mayor
you probably have a real relationship
with her I do I feel like if for people
who aren't from Chicago or don't pay
attention
to like what actually is going on there
we just see like memes and [ __ ] and like
you know I think the memes is just like
something funny but I've literally never
heard anybody say anything like she's
solid yeah she's solid in the city she's
solid she don't do no [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
what I'm saying excuse my language she
don't do nothing nothing that is not
beneficial to her people that's amazing
and I love her for that well I wanna
because I feel like there's like the
wrong narrative about her sometimes no
nah she don't do nothing that's not
beneficial to her people or to the city
of Chicago in general you feel I'm
saying it ain't just about the trenches
she looking out for the city of Chicago
and it's beneficial on all ends and
that's a very poverty struck in
neighborhood she benefit the rich
neighborhood it's such a company in his
own the entrepreneur it's a very
complicated City to overlook it's a very
complicated City you gotta imagine
because if you go to the north side well
she they own a ass about carjackers this
and the smallest [ __ ] and it's like
she can't do nothing about that right
when they come to the end
we got the most influence ain't nobody
in the [ __ ] trenches from the listen
to Lori and also they're not completely
honest yeah and even if they put like my
thing is is like you know a lot of
people are like well you know
uh we always think of Chicago as like
the whenever gun violence gets discussed
yeah Chicago always gets brought up
automatically and it's like
I don't think like you you'll see
conservative politicians always use
Chicago as like a [ __ ] you to the left
like what about Chicago and I think it's
very like irresponsible because what
they they don't understand the reality
of certain areas of this country not
just Chicago but like putting more
police on the south side of Chicago is
not going to do anything it's not it's
gonna make everything even more worse
it's gonna make at least go because at
the end of the day the police and I give
I'm gonna give you credit on the outside
looking in you only looking at trying
your job to try to make this [ __ ] better
which you don't [ __ ] know how is with
using force and a lot of these police
aren't you trying neighborhood you're
not from the neighborhood you don't know
these [ __ ] kids from mechanic pain
you looking at them like they kill me
immediately that's how you thinking the
police to kill you they looking like
he'll kill me cause they're objective
they're just like your objectives to get
home to their kids get home yeah the
main objective is getting home no matter
what the [ __ ] you do the main objective
is getting home that's the name of the
game you feel what I'm saying and I
understand that so it's like like with
understanding that you got to think
with all the kids and the [ __ ] that's
carrying guns and doing all this WOW
[ __ ]
you got to compare it to something
simple like basketball you feel me like
when you were real uh Elite athlete you
got that dog in you when I get on that
hardwood I'm killing anybody I don't get
no [ __ ] view my favorite player
that's why I love John morent I don't
give a [ __ ] if you my favorite if you
get in front of me well I'm trying to go
I want to go to the championship yeah
that's the [ __ ] getting home is the
championship in the trenches [ __ ] I'm
gonna do whatever necessary it's the
championship of the trenches and it's
also the championship of being a cop I'm
just the cops in the trenches that's the
name of the game the cops is in the
trenches with us that's the name of the
game I'm trying to win the championship
so I gotta get home so we're saying that
I'm saying [ __ ] who all in when you
doing all this and I'm talking from the
outside looking in but I understand
when [ __ ] up against this [ __ ] and
they carrying guns and they doing all
this wild [ __ ] and all this killing you
know what they trying to get to the
championship they trying to eliminate
the competition to get home yeah that's
why all the killing going on right
[ __ ] want to get home bro they don't
want to carry them [ __ ] guns you
thinking they're going to end up in the
county you think they're gonna want to
go to jail you think they're going to
want to die don't nobody want that they
want to live like me right [ __ ] want to
live like me how all the [ __ ] that I got
going on so I'm gonna show you how to
live like me do you think Snoop did this
in La where he had uh met with the
sheriff the L.A County Sheriff to try to
help kind of bridge the gap between like
maybe some of the misunderstandings
between the police and the community and
obviously it's a very
rough place when the cops ain't from the
community you know you I always feel
like when there's community policing
where it's like yo this is where I'm
from I live I grew up here whatever
there's a lot more understanding there's
a lot more compassion
um will that ever be something you'd be
interested in doing like maybe trying to
help assist like the police not assist
them to like arrest people but assist
them in understanding hell yeah yeah
that's important to me bro because we
need police if something happened to my
mom machine from the call nobody but the
[ __ ] police right we need police bro
I agree we need responsible please
responsibilities we need police that's
in the city that understand we know your
name [ __ ] your mama live right here she
here she good like that's how it used to
be and they could get to that because
I'm I come from a foundation bro I used
I listen to my old my mama stories my
daddy stories oh his stories were like
the whole neighbor I used to when I was
growing up they say the whole
neighborhood could whip your ass you did
something the neighbor beating your ass
right here you finna get your ass beat
right here in front of this house for
doing something I got I dare you uh
neighbors know your mama ain't trying to
come touch one of these kids man gonna
get your ass shot yeah
right it was different back then my mom
and them said the neighbors used to be
able to beat their ass and tell yeah he
did this told a mama she thank you and
then you never ask me about it yeah yeah
I guarantee you somebody off the
neighborhood that know your mama go try
to run up on them man they go if they
don't they gonna beat your ass yeah they
need to get back to that
you used to get the Govern our
neighborhood control our neighborhood
police our neighborhood secure our
neighborhoods that's the only way it's
going to be safe for us because at the
end of the day we the only neighborhoods
that don't do it the white neighborhoods
do it the Irish the Jewish the whatever
the Arab every all these communities do
it you know what I'm saying and I admire
that there's no way that I could ever be
a racist because I admired a way that
people stick together we need that you
feel I'm saying we need that for
ourselves I could never even think about
another culture and how they look at us
because they look at us like y'all crazy
as hell right y'all don't give a [ __ ]
about each other how the [ __ ] we gonna
care about y'all
it's impossible we gotta care about each
other first ain't nobody gonna give a
[ __ ] about us we don't care about each
other why why should they yeah I mean I
ain't gonna give a [ __ ] about a [ __ ]
that don't care about itself like I said
I know you can't help everybody so if
I'm trying to do this and a [ __ ] ain't
trying to help itself and get no money
what the [ __ ] I'm fixing to still try to
give you some money for
as a as a black man that's how we think
so how the [ __ ] you think somebody on
the outside looking what the [ __ ] I'm
helping them for they ain't doing
nothing but killing each other
it's the same thing bro universal law is
the same no matter how you look at it
bro we got to think about universal law
and principle that's the only way we're
gonna get better yeah man I mean I think
a lot of people in your position should
preach that yeah but all right bro I
just I just grew bro I'm just a grown
man I look at life totally different bro
cause I got [ __ ] that I care about you
got yeah you got children hey man I feel
like once you have kids man you take
that father [ __ ] seriously do everything
serious bro I can't I can't lose I can't
lose in no way I can't lose right you
gotta
I'm assuming
Conway's on the
the pain version okay because I know
Conway's got that pain you know that car
we on the B side you know Conway is one
of one of my favorite uh rappers in the
world and no Benny liked the puppet he
found yeah yeah he's like Benny's like
the pop star Griselda if any like the
pop this [ __ ] yeah Conway is like the
pain you know that you know what I'm
saying it came perfect bro I told I told
me I said no I need both of them on
there the fact you got me on the ASAP
[ __ ] crazy nah nah uh shout out to both
of them like uh how how in tune have you
been with what griselda's doing with
both with both of those guys I've always
been in tune from the beginning I'm a
fan of Benny Conway gone yeah I'm a fan
of Griselda period you know what I'm
saying so
Benny that's my brother me and Benny
been knowing each other since 2014.
great we don't even know that I say that
all the time people don't even know go
back and look me and Benny got songs
from 2014. I'd have been a buffalo [ __ ]
with him in this Hood yeah
I'm saying so Conway always been a fan
of it and I'm just telling Mick like man
I gotta do what you feel me like I'm in
the traffic when I get in traffic I'm
playing that [ __ ] bro I'm playing Benny
[ __ ] I'm playing Conway [ __ ] like you
know what I'm saying but it was certain
times you know you go through some [ __ ]
mentally you only hit one song yeah you
feel me like
um
Conway when he when he came to God the
album oh my intro
song every day it's a [ __ ] classic I
used to listen to that song the intro
that's the one with Dej Loaf right no
God oh yeah James loaf is track two yeah
and that guy used to get in the car and
listen to that song every day soon as I
got in the car it's a classic album
[ __ ] I know that's what I'm telling you
I listen to that [ __ ] every single day
when I got in the car bro so good
yeah some of the bars on that album just
some of the [ __ ] he was saying man [ __ ]
different it's different Conway's in my
opinion like when it comes to just like
lines that you're just like like I just
feel it in my voice
like Tupac had that like Conway's got
that where he's just like [ __ ] like I
got goosebumps because I felt you on
that [ __ ] no [ __ ] oh man that [ __ ]
different bro I love that [ __ ] he's
different for real food I told him that
I'll give him his fly I'm gonna get any
real [ __ ] flowers I got two no I
thought it was dope you had both of them
on it obviously gun is on the project uh
it's looking like he's probably laughing
yeah free gun or free slime man free my
twin and for I can't wait we gotta stop
the interview tell you about our
partners at Odd Socks well first of all
let's check out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg capsock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
gonna figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been walking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too that's an odd sock
right there that's an odd sock basic you
know what I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd
Socks you should too they got the crazy
licenses we're talking about Nickelodeon
shout out to Patrick [ __ ]
Cheez-Its Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
all together bootleg Kev and you will
save 20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by odd
Sox and we are proud to say so all right
let's get back to the interview yeah I
think I mean man obviously one of the
craziest things that happened in a long
time
with the rap lyric [ __ ] California just
passed the
the law that uh that's great they can't
use it that's great yeah is that
something that like uh
at this point in time in your career you
think about what you say on records
because it could be misperceived I don't
I don't even think about how people miss
miss perceive me or miss I'm here for
what I'm here for I feel like God put me
here to do what I'm meant to do in life
and I don't think about it bro I'm gonna
be honest I'm gonna be transparent I'm
gonna be myself and at the end of the
day all I ever did was try to help
people so
it is what it is I don't even think too
much about it I promise talk to like
Thug's character because everybody I
know just says he's just the greatest
guy he's the most generous guy [ __ ] the
most solid [ __ ] [ __ ] one of the most
solid [ __ ] you're gonna ever meet in
life if I'm saying that it's crazy like
he just so smart I heard that [ __ ] like
people would think like this were one of
the things that really stood out to me
about the like not [ __ ] the fact that he
a genuine [ __ ] everybody that no Thug
know that everybody no Thug no he care
about everybody around him just how
smart he is musically and how you try to
help other people that [ __ ] told me he
said [ __ ] think like
oh what I'm doing y'all this [ __ ]
tripping you know it's weird [ __ ] but
who the [ __ ] gonna be the Rick James of
this generation we don't have he said
that yeah I said damn slide that's you
that [ __ ] you know what I'm saying like
for the prince or the free the print he
said both of them he said Prince Aaron
James like who's the Andre 3000 of this
already being that [ __ ] though yeah all
the [ __ ]
a gangster you know what I'm saying a
[ __ ] that's don't buy gangster what I
mean is stand on Ten and stand on what
you believe in and empower the people
around you and and be 100 completely
yourself no matter what nobody say and
ain't nobody gonna ain't nobody gonna
ever walk up to Thug and say I don't
like how you did this no
so what I mean by that is when he said
that bro it it threw me out it gave me a
whole another different like outlook on
him like nah this [ __ ] he right it's a
different [ __ ] he's serious this the
type of [ __ ] that's like going to
change Generations you know what I'm
saying slime just a genuine [ __ ] and at
all every song I got with him he told me
to get on I promise the song I put out
on swervo the the [ __ ] we got on the
album other [ __ ] I ain't never since
Thug a record ever he always like huh
jump on this you can have it he told you
could have this [ __ ]
we had snapdog on the show and he was
like yeah I was I've been hanging out
with Doug the last couple years and he
noticed I would need glasses all right
squint yeah yeah no I was with him when
he did it when I was always all together
in the studio yeah he snapped through he
was like Snap when he got his ass
surgery the next day
Doug was like yeah yeah that's crazy I'm
saying that's so crazy we was together I
literally we was in the studio together
that was around the same time we did
brief slow this on how crazy is that
though he sent snap to go get his ass
surgery because he saw him squinting
that's a great [ __ ] bro it's not no
[ __ ] nobody's doing that who the [ __ ]
finna see you squinting say man you good
[ __ ] paid for his ass surgery bro I
swear to God he's in the studio we was
all together me and snap did a song that
day and me and Thug did a song that day
and the next morning snap went and got
his eye surgery [ __ ] I was there and
Thug covered it I was there that shit's
so crazy
and I'm just like yo that's some High
character [ __ ] a [ __ ] is solid that
dude's not signed to him you know what I
mean he's just the right [ __ ] huh yeah
what you need you good if I'm saying
like that's real bro that's a real [ __ ]
bro you feel me like even watching the
untrapped [ __ ] with baby that [ __ ] ain't
no game bro that [ __ ] get him whatever
he gave baby whatever the [ __ ] he wanted
to go rap
you feel me this ain't that's just being
a good-hearted [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying if you able to do it it ain't
hurting him and you think that [ __ ]
don't hurt the hood to go get a [ __ ]
this or get a [ __ ] some shine if I'm
saying it don't you know and I feel like
as a people that's why we supposed to be
even more adamant and Advocate about
making sure that that man and his kids
is protected by all costs whatever it is
you know what I'm saying 100 whatever
why he going whatever whatever happens
happens whatever he's making sure he's
good and straight by any means you know
what I'm saying it like
I talked to like Dolly his sister and
she like that yeah whatever slam me good
if I'm saying [ __ ] like that but at the
end of the day and I understand that
they're not gonna let nobody really in
for real if I'm saying because of course
so I got a serious situation yeah you
just gotta really pray that he overcome
that [ __ ] and just embrace it Whatever
by any means anything that anybody ever
called me on behalf of the gun or any
[ __ ] I [ __ ] with I promise you I'm
hands on immediately you could call me
and whatever I'm gonna make a way to do
it because I understand it if I'm saying
whatever any [ __ ] I [ __ ] with whether
it's somebody this big or this big I
promise if it's anything I could do to
help I'm gonna do it
you mention the little baby documentary
would you ever
um let someone kind of tell your story
that way yeah yeah yeah you know I
already I already want to do some [ __ ]
like that well you know what I was
thinking was like we think of uh 50 and
like kind of how he's had power and he's
had BMF and like you I mean obviously
Showtime has a Chiraq show
but I feel like
somebody in your position Dirk's
position somebody like that should like
take it upon themselves to do it
theyself to tell that story by because
you know what's going to happen is in
like five years or ten years somebody
else one day we're gonna wake up and on
Netflix there's gonna be a [ __ ] show
that's based or it's gonna be like the
wire of Chicago
and it's going to be someone else taking
advantage let nobody take advantage of
our story we know but someone's gonna
try to do it dude nobody gonna tell our
narrative because we already own it you
know what I'm saying it's going to be
too we already own it you feel me know
like I think I tell my story for me I
don't even mean yours I just mean like
anybody the city of Chicago bro I'm
telling you that's why Unity is so
important because at the end of the day
you could you got to think about it like
I could tell stories about Sosa from my
own perspective my own point of view
Dirk could tell stories about me I could
tell stories about Dirk right I could
tell stories about Polo he could tell a
story you know what I'm saying so we
gotta come together and just build the
career about that way just build the
crib together Unity why would we let
anybody else or while we do it
separately when at the end of the day
this [ __ ] alone this little [ __ ] that we
just coming together for two three
months could feed a hundred families
some [ __ ] we just putting together and
like that together though yeah together
that's important Unity is what I'm
preaching that's the most important [ __ ]
that's that's big from a city that is
known to not have a lot of that exactly
yeah what is uh for you you just
mentioned all those artists shout out to
Polo G shout out to Dirk would you guys
ever do like a [ __ ] crazy tour I
would love it we've been all like people
already got it in their head I'm sure
every last person that I named and
thought about it you know what I'm
saying but we just got to put it into
perspective you know what I'm saying
ain't no and you know something that I
learned like I I was preaching that when
I was a kid like in the streets like
ain't no big ass a little use I always
remember that ain't no big ass or a
little use
you got to remember that no big ass or a
little use if I'm saying it's like we
all equal we all I don't look at myself
above nobody you know what I'm saying
let's do make me bigger than you money
don't make you bigger than me you know
what I'm saying like at the end of the
day we all have things that we could
learn from you know I'm saying within
each other yeah so once you look at life
like that no big ass a little use it'll
make you like all right bet we could put
[ __ ] together have you uh taken it upon
yourself at all to be a big homie to any
of the young artists coming up and
because I mean I'm sure that there's
artists that you see making mistakes
that maybe you've made in the past
um yeah I don't mind like talking about
like my mistakes that I made or like you
know what I'm saying [ __ ]
um that I've been through that I could
try to help other artists right you know
what I'm saying come from under and I
just I feel like my my position in this
[ __ ] is really just trying to
just light another candle like if I
could do anything to just make your [ __ ]
bigger if I could give you a verse a
look or anything pop out on the machine
yeah you're definitely bringing you out
I'm gonna do that if I'm saying it don't
make me no never mind I don't give a
[ __ ] I don't even gotta know you
personally I could just know somebody
that managed you I can know your cousin
and oh yeah I [ __ ] with you well I see
you I see you popping up on the albums
like I loved when I saw you on mozzy's
album like there's certain like [ __ ]
where I'm just my Aussie my brother
don't know that I'm gonna always say I'm
gonna always put my health demise if I'm
saying free bro that's my brother yeah I
always had love for Mozzy since the
beginning [ __ ] I haven't spent weeks in
Sacramento when [ __ ] just telling me
like yeah this [ __ ] ain't Mozzy it's
like 2013 right 2014. you feel me like
yeah but for all of this [ __ ] before I
was even as big you know what I'm saying
like so I said that's my brother I'm
always I'mma always show love to any
[ __ ] that I can no matter who it is bro
I got tires for [ __ ] from
this city that city this city because I
just did solid [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying and I don't even use I probably
might get to a [ __ ] City don't even
call and be like all right what's up
let's link because I'm thinking about so
much [ __ ] I got so much going on I don't
even get a chance to really tap in but
I'm already tapped in because I did some
solid [ __ ] you feel me
the new album uh
go run that [ __ ] up is there what else
is on the way for you more man yes uh
survivors of Morris 10-7 man b side 10
10. I'm excited for everything new
artists on the way uh and people don't
really know how I said like me and
Sizzle already been working on big
swerve while we working on survivors or
more so
I'm in mold bro I'm not letting up I
ain't gonna lie how I'm feeling right
now I'm not really taking the foot off
the gas right now what is your like
label situation are you kind of like
still independent I was about to say
you're independent for people today
entertainment Republicans for people who
don't know you're like you're
independent yeah I'm independent fully
yeah independent a lot of people I don't
think a lot of people realize that yeah
because you do a lot of [ __ ] that you
know people like yo he's got to be
no I'm independent man you know we even
built this [ __ ] from the ground up you
know and that's the importance of it I
did all the hard [ __ ] bro yeah and take
no shortcuts bro I ain't got no big
looks underneath this album right now
while I'm already Big G herbo outside
[ __ ] I've been outside for two years
right I was on side on the phone with
Sizzle ever since my little brother died
my little brother died January 28
2021 right right Craig died in 21 last
year January 28th so from there until
now I've been outside thugging I just
been outside just doing me and I feel
like that's what's building that but
guess what that's trauma that I've been
dealing with I ain't go outside to
become I need to turn my [ __ ] up [ __ ] I
was outside to just just to try to feel
just just to kind of and just try to get
over the [ __ ] out get over the grief bro
I lost my little brother and then it was
everything to me you know what I'm
saying so to be able to like be where I
am now and be independent and everything
just makes sense to me because I bet on
myself no matter what I'm going through
the hardest toughest [ __ ] what I'm
trying to say is I ain't take no
shortcuts I ain't take no easy roads or
none of this [ __ ] I built this [ __ ]
from the ground up fan by fan fan by fan
[ __ ] I built this [ __ ] from the ground
up and I don't even pop it like that I
don't even pop my [ __ ] but at the end of
the day it is what it is [ __ ] Ain't
done without doing I ain't had no big
looks I ain't had no major label push I
ain't had nothing every partnership I
built every relationship I build every
feature I got every song I did every two
I did [ __ ] I did the roughest toughest
[ __ ] I built this [ __ ] from the ground
up and can't nobody take that from me so
I deserve everything that I'm coming
that's coming to me do you feel like
somebody who's taken that path that is
extremely the hard path the long way
right yeah do you feel like when you see
like artists talking about their black
ball do you feel like that's a real
thing
um
I feel like it is a real thing
but it's not you feel me I feel like
when artists say they black ball it's
about accountability [ __ ] you
blackballed yourself at the end of the
day you feel I'm saying it's about
certain things you've done or certain
things you may have said or ways you may
have done it but at the end of the day
you're not wrong for that right you're
not wrong for being yourself this is an
industry full of reasons why [ __ ]
Can't Be they self right it's a fake ass
industry it's a [ __ ] industry it's
an industry full of [ __ ] that's afraid
to be they self so at the end of the day
when you feel like you blackballed you
may be but at the end of the day [ __ ]
even if you are I promise you it's
always late at the end of the tunnel
Real [ __ ] Gonna always win so if
you're a real [ __ ] just be yourself and
do the next best thing if I'm saying
like black ball and it is real is true
but at the end of the day but they can
only blackball you so much so much
because the internet's still there yeah
the internet is so when you try to build
and bet on yourself and do the next best
thing if I'm saying that's the that's
the thing that's why I don't believe in
the black ball because they internet is
so powerful it's so powerful and if the
internet can't blackball you if they
[ __ ] with you if the industry blackball
you and the internet [ __ ] with you
you're gonna still win NBA young that's
why young boys still winning NBA young
boy period you feel me people gotta [ __ ]
with you NBA youngboy is the most
anti-industry best of the most
anti-industry [ __ ] ever you from saying
You Gotta Give a [ __ ] they they credit
yeah you know what I'm saying I saw yeah
I saw that's what I mean did you see
what Russ just said
pretty much was like you know
it's not as long as the internet is
alive and you have fans you have fans
you can't be friends it's impossible bro
you know what I'm saying so people have
to like you said people have to take
accountability take accountability and
just say all right look in the mirror
look in the mirror say I bet let me
build even if you want to apologize on
the internet let me just think about
myself right now 100 build this [ __ ]
back up organically from the mud because
if you're a hustler or a street [ __ ]
you know you're gonna go down to zero
get yourself back up you got to
understand that's the name of the game
don't take this [ __ ] personal [ __ ] when
you take a loss don't blame the labels
don't blame nobody in the mirror
I [ __ ] up yeah let me get this [ __ ]
right Point Blank period that's that's
just is what it is it's how humility is
missing man this is what it is yeah
accountability and humility two two
traits every grown man should have now I
know that and I understand that because
I built this [ __ ] from the ground yeah
and [ __ ] when [ __ ] was over here
betting on that they like I'm betting on
this yeah and then when that [ __ ] ain't
work now [ __ ] Back betting on me but
you wasn't betting on me then I was
betting on myself so you could never
blackball me I could never take it
personal I'm not gonna look at you like
oh you a [ __ ] [ __ ] you was [ __ ] with
him two years ago now you [ __ ] with
me all right bet appreciate you for
[ __ ] with me yeah I [ __ ] with you too
yeah that's where I'm at that's I don't
care about none of this [ __ ] Bro take
that [ __ ] personal bro well listen the
album is out by the time this drops yeah
I'm gonna be out or it'll be coming out
the next day ASAP be sad listen man I'm
super proud of you you're killing it
appreciate it I cannot wait to hear this
album yeah I ain't gonna lie it's like
the orange is like how I'm feeling right
now it just make me like it make me
think about [ __ ] different I'm a pop it
different I'm gonna be humble different
I'm gonna be cocky different like
everything it's I feel like it's just a
next level for me in life you know I'm
saying I'm just grateful to be leveling
up on all levels I'm just grateful
career-wise mentality wise now we just
got to get you some mushrooms yeah nah
for sure I'm gonna [ __ ] with it but I
don't [ __ ] with it yeah there it is man
G herbo yeah
fire